yesterday a major incident was declared
in the capital by the mayor of london
that's as the rapid spread of covet 19
threatens to overwhelm its hospitals and
with data estimating that
one in 30 londoners now have the virus
how is the intensive care units in the
hospitals around london coping
well dr zudin putherteri is a council
member of the intensive care society
he's also a critical care consultant and
he joins me now
from central london uh good morning to
you dr
pithacheri um just describe for us a
little bit what it's like
in intensive care units in london at the
moment
so the intensive care units are
they're full beyond bursting at the
moment there are
more patients than we've ever had we've
have less staff than we've ever had
and it's not just the intensive care
units the hospital
the wards run by our respiratory
physician colleagues our geriatricians
everywhere is full beyond bursting if
there's a space
for patient they're there we've
cannibalized staff from all around the
hospital volunteers are pouring in
to try and look after these patients and
deliver the best care we can
staff are breaking themselves to make
this place
make this happen and to keep our
patients safe and it's not
going to be enough well that
you're making that point it's coming
over very loud and clear and it was said
in the previous wave that people who
went into intensive care had
roughly a 50 50 chance of surviving with
the
panoply of new treatments available has
that improved or is that
still looking the same thank you so
there are two points to make here
at the moment patients if you come to
intensive care with cavanagh virus
seven out of ten people will survive so
thirty percent of people will die
but those seventy percent of people will
be disabled for
years to come because they lose so much
muscle you lose
almost two kilos if i was if i was sick
on with coronavirus
on intensive care i would lose about two
kilos of muscle
every day i'm on intensive care and i'll
probably be there for two to three weeks
you can see and you can think and feel
how long
that will affect me for for literally
for years
yeah it's a stark reminder isn't it and
and the age of patients that are in
intensive care what is the range
so the average age is 60 right
90 of our patients all had work
working before they came to us they had
normal lives so
the majority of patients i look after
are my age they
they look like me they look like my wife
they look like my friends
they have children the same age as i do
they are they are young people i'm 46 i
think i'm reasonably young
and fit and these are the patients i'm
looking after and this is
the same all around the country this is
what we are seeing
and are these people who does it include
people who had no underlying health
conditions
so that's a really great statement so i
have a really
obvious condition i've got
osteoarthritis with my knee that's an
underlying health condition so
yes includes people who have arthritis
maybe a broken finger
the term underlying heart condition a
health condition
is a made-up term that is meaningless to
our patients and meaningless to us it's
just
it doesn't mean anything everybody you
know the people within sky tv who have
underlying
health conditions okay i want to make it
very very clear from an intensive care
point of view we treat people without
prejudice and we do the best health care
we can to keep people's
quality of life whether they have an
underlying health condition is
irrelevant
um there are some articles in the papers
this morning and talking about
the decisions that need to be made by
people running intensive care units and
they're effectively deciding
uh who lives and who doesn't is is that
a reality in london hospitals
thank you that's a really really
important question and a really really
important point so
through the first wave of the pandemic
and now the legal
moral and ethical stance of intensive
care doctors
has not changed we treat people without
prejudice
and our priority is the patient in front
of us
okay and we are still there what we're
talking about
and that major incident signals is that
decision making capacity
may well be taken away from the
intensive care consultants
and been made because of resource
limitation
by politicians uh and other people who
make us
i would say that from an intensive care
point of view we
have not changed our legal moral and
ethical stance
which is to prioritize the patient in
front of us
right okay um i mean you're talking very
it's very clear talking to you
that resources are absolutely stretched
uh
to the very limit in terms of caring for
these patients in intensive care
what are the biggest challenges at the
moment the single biggest challenge
is staff we don't have enough
critical care nursing staff we don't
have enough doctors we have volunteers
coming in
we have very very senior doctors doctors
with no training with coming into work
both as junior doctors and to support
our nursing staff
it is amazing as i said before the level
of which people are willing to break
themselves to support the nhs
is awe-inspiring but it's not turning
out to be enough because you can't just
magic up a critical canvas it takes
years and years and years of training
you can't magic up a critical care
consultant it takes
years and years of training so it's
going to be staff it's not beds it's not
equipment
it's staff that's going to be the single
greatest bottleneck for us
i don't have a solution before you ask
me i don't know what the solution is
and that really really scares me
yeah i can i can hear it in your voice
and uh dr peter cherry um
the front line are supposed to be in the
priority group
for receiving the vaccine how many
intensivists
have been able to have the vaccine so i
can't speak
widely because the situation uh is
is changing rapidly but as far as i'm
aware um
frontline staff are being prioritized
many many intensivists are receiving
their vaccine
and many of our intensive care nursing
staff are receiving at the vaccine
and if there's a message for the public
out there
coming from you coming from your
colleagues working in hospitals
particularly in intensive care
what would it be i guess the message
would be
that i'm scared
and i'm angry and those are the two
feelings that we all have
i'm scared but because we're reaching a
point
where where someone might tell us that
we can't
prioritize our patients above everything
else that going the extra mile for the
patient in front of us is not going to
be good enough
and those decisions are going to be
taken away from us and none of us have
ever lived through that none of us have
ever experienced that and we've fought
long and hard against it and that's
what's coming our way
i'm scared because this is not the big
this is not the beginning you heard from
someone in sorry earlier on
that we're coming to the end of the
pandemic well every time we have a
patient
that comes in actually the ramifications
go on forever it's not just the
rehabilitation
it's the cancer patients who won't get
their operations in the summer and the
spring
the legacy of this pandemic will destroy
2021
and will continue to destroy the nhs and
that's what i'm scared about
and i'm angry just like all the other
stuff
that people are not listening we hear
today that the tfl football is twice
that
of what it was in the last uh in the
first wave so we're having
twice as many people out there doing
things on a saturday
when they should be at home it's no i'm
angry because we're talking about
protecting the nhs and that's clearly
failed when we should be talking about
protecting the healthcare of the nation
that is what's suffering right now not
the nhs the nhs is breaking in front of
us and there's no plan to stop it
breaking
we need to stop the health of the nation
breaking and that's
where we've got to that's why i'm angry
and that's why all our staff are angry
okay dr susan pithacheria really good to
talk to you thank you for your time
and for getting your message out there
on sky news thank you